regression is a story of a detective
played by Ethan Hawke who's
investigating something that took place
with Emma Watson she claims to have been
abused physically by a cult that has
arisen in this small town and it's a
story of how Ethan Hawke investigates
this mystery as well as the strange line
that sometimes gets blurred between
fiction and truth and I was excited for
this movie because the director of this
film made the very good the others this
is a really good scary thriller plus I
love Ethan Hawke I think he's a very
understated actor and I always loved
seeing him in roles and I'm always
curious to see what Emma Watson can do
outside of the Harry Potter universe
what I really liked about regression is
it's very old-fashioned some might say
to a fault the style in which this film
is directed is very old-school and I
think that's awesome this doesn't feel
current at all it doesn't feel like 2016
it feels like a movie that could have
come out 10 or 20 years ago and that's
something that I really appreciated
because it did feel very restrained it
didn't feel too flashy and sometimes I
want to film like this to be a little
more in-your-face and exciting but it
suspense film like this that really at
its core is actually more of a mystery I
think really benefited from that
approach and I also loved Ethan Hawke in
this movie he plays a very tortured
character and one that is dealing with a
lot of paranoia because that's a major
theme of this film how someone can
explain a story and someone else here
said story and repeat said story and it
goes on and on to the point where shock
and terror and paranoia is just taking
over this little town and it's loosely
based on true events of the early 90s
and when I was growing up I do remember
hearing just slight whispers of certain
things like this and so it's definitely
touching on something that is true the
way a story can be perpetuated from one
person to another until it builds into
this thing that just terrifies everybody
Emma Watson in this movie I thought she
was fine she wasn't amazing she wasn't
great she served her character's purpose
and once you see the film and you see
where everything goes with every
character certain things that maybe at
first didn't quite make sense start to
make sense as you watch more of the
movie now here's where I guess my
opinion gets kind of controversial for
some reason because when I went to
Rotten Tomatoes and saw the reviews for
this movie I was floored
how many critics are truly hating on
this movie it has such a low percentage
and way lower than some of the other
horror films that have already come out
in Jan you
worried that are far worse and don't
even come close to being as well
directed as this movie was so I don't
understand why I have this rift going on
right now because usually I tend to be a
little bit more on the side of the
critics and stuff but I'm not feeling it
I can't really explain this rift I'm
having right now with rod tomatoes in
this movie but I found it a lot better
than critics are saying I think it is a
fairly well directed and very well acted
movie it does have problems though and
those problems are its ending I won't
spoil it but it's the type of ending
that makes you kind of feel as if the
film was kind of lit it's sort of
disappointing in the way that the film
slightly deflates it's almost like the
film was harnessing that human emotion
that we get when paranoia or fear builds
and it just worked for me it makes the
film a little less impactful and overall
the film as a whole I can see how it
might bore some because it is
old-fashioned I appreciated that though
and I liked the performances but some
will be bored by this movie and some
will hate the ending and that's why I'm
going to give regression a B it's a
field that has narrative problems the
ending doesn't entirely work but I
appreciated the ride this movie had me
on for the majority of it I'm curious to
know what you guys think of this movie
if you had a chance to see it it's in a
very limited release right now it's only
playing in one or two theaters in my
area I really hope you guys get a chance
to see it and I want to know what other
people think of this movie too and if
it's just me I'm just like the one guy
who's like it's okay it's not that bad
actually thank you so much guys for
watching it if you like this you can
click right here and get steppen eyes
you